oh good morning everyone so my name is
Bhargav
is my full name you can just call me gov
because my name is really massive what
we're going to be doing today is text
analysis I will be doing more of a
breath kind of thing than a depth so I'm
going to introduce you all to a really
large variety of tools that you can use
in the context of Python and text
analysis so that you can all go home or
go wherever and then actually do these
things on your own on your own laptops
or whatever machines you're using so the
idea is to kind of allow everyone to be
able to do all of these cool things
outside of this tutorial as well and
also to understand what kind of tools
are available because I think what
happens especially in data analysis in
general but also in text analysis is
that you're kind of overwhelmed with all
the different kinds of tools and you're
not sure where to start what does what
exactly and where do I get data what's
even going on so I'm gonna try and
streamline this process for you a little
bit make people aware of the kind of
things you can do and how you're gonna
go about doing it and that's going to be
the general theme of this tutorial a few
things before we actually get started
how many of you all have installed all
the requirements or set up a super
anaconda or a virtual environment or
something can have a hands up briefly
for those who have okay that is very
cool so I understand there are some
people who might not have this set up
and while it would be ideal to have this
set up for the purpose of this tutorial
I'm going to be walking you all through
a Jupiter notebook and we're going to be
going through that but that being said
there's a lot of information in this
tutorial so the only real thing you all
will be doing is pressing shift enter
Jupiter cell which is not a lot I mean
there are of course a few things like
looking at the contents of a particular
list or something but you will which I
will also be doing on my own Jupiter
notebook but my point the point of me
saying this is if you somehow it could
not have got your entire setup ready it
is okay it is not a huge problem what I
would need you to do is you should have
also got an email yesterday if you were
in if you're signed up for toriel's with
the link to the github repository which
has my code if you don't I'm gonna help
just show you this briefly
it's really mad okay you can search up
I'm just gonna write this down if you
don't have it but it's Bargo Vader which
is my first name and like Darth Vader
like we ate year after that so it's it's
bar go Vader this is my personal github
repository and it's slash personal so if
you just go to github.com slash bar go
waiter slash personal yeah I could do
that definitely um I think I can hold on
sorry haha friendly okay hold on I'm not
sure how to make zoom in on using oh
there we go
what oh yeah sure although I'm just
gonna try that again
Oh neat okay so yeah okay so please yeah
you're also more than welcome to keep
stopping me if you have any problems
with regard to the how it's being done
or if I'm not saying something clearly
basically to find this tutorial you'd
want to go to github.com slash bar go
waiter slash personal slash notebooks
over here I actually sent this link over
yesterday in case you do not have this
link let's just take a second if you do
not have all of this set up to go over
here and find this so you'd want to go
to text analysis tutorial and in the
readme I talked about what you would all
be needing so I'm gonna spend around
five minutes to just kind of find this
particular page if there any problems in
finding this page please put your hand
up and I'll get you to find it so again
it's github.com slash harga waiter slash
personal than notebooks and text
analysis tutorial so ideally if you do
have if you would have got this and
downloaded and had like your environment
set up that would be really really great
I've also given instructions on how to
do this it's basically setting up
original environment and downloading
using pip or whatever you would like to
use from the requirements file and then
running the Jupiter notebook if anyway
again if anyone needs any help with
regard to this I'm over here I'm just
going to give so it's 11:05 I'm way
- 11:10 to kind of get people over here
so I'll just get five minutes for
everyone to find this
also just to note that even if you
cannot find this I will be running all
of these notebooks on my machine and
you'll be able to see all of that and I
will be talking about it it's just gonna
be a lot easier if you also have it in
front of your computer and I will also
be talking about like I would encourage
you folks to all try out different
Jupiter cells if it needs to be done but
that yeah okay cool I was just saying
that you don't absolutely need this page
it'll just be very useful sure so it's a
Python it's Python 3 3.5 3.6 check but
that being said I also I mean you can
use Python 2 for this tutorial as well I
have if you do then I have a few code
snippets you probably need to use
because of the Unicode and because we're
dealing with textual data so of course
we need to be very clear about the
unicode part but apart from that you
could use Python to Python 3 you don't
even need a virtual environment that was
this what I use or you can use PI ax and
R anacondas whatever you want you can
use anything it's just mine would be on
Python with Python 3
another note is if you all plan to
install all the requirements right now
it might take some time because spacy
has a language model which is I think
like 45 M you're like depending on what
size it might take some time in which
case I mean you could probably have it
running on in the background this the
installation but again I would like to
make it clear it's not absolutely
necessary for you to all get something
out of this tutorial
though it would be very very nice if
it's installed so that when you have
time to go through this on your own you
can so the space C language model which
I will talk about in detail of course
but I have a link over there which talks
about it and how to do it and these are
the Python packages will be using
Jupiter for running the notebook Jensen
for topic modeling matplotlib for
plotting Spacey for other text analysis
and some visualizations yeah
yeah yeah so there's no so I've
mentioned that over here requirements
underscore one is the one for text
analysis which would have Jupiter Jensen
Matt so there are two tutorials in this
so you have topic modeling and you have
text analysis we will be doing text
analysis so I believe that the
requirements underscore one file has the
ones for the tutorial we'll be doing no
problem
cool it's 11 tents I'm going to start
again just a note because I realize
there's a lot of installations and a lot
of things you might want to set up it
would be very very nice if you could all
spend some time after the tutorial or
during the time of the conference to
actually install all the things I've
talked about here because they're going
to be allow you to do this on your own
of course so that you're not just stuck
to what's going to what I'm going to be
talking about in this tutorial but if
there are problems with installations
and things like that starting right now
I will not be talking about those right
away because I will be spending the rest
of the time to actually talk about the
tutorial so are there any questions
before I start any problems everything
okay awesome
so is this okay can everyone see this or
is the perfect level of zoom yeah cool
awesome so we're gonna be doing text
analysis text analysis is data analysis
where our data is text now what I
personally find where you need about
text analysis is that it's very easy to
actually get this data and it can also
be personal and things that you care
about I find sometimes in your generic
data analysis you might get kind of lost
and the numbers are not very interested
in what you're trying to do like this
more common data set is I think the
Boston housing data set for regression
it's kind of boring predicting the
prices as the iris data set because
again not super fun so what for me what
I personally like about text analysis is
I can use whatever text I want to you
can pick up tweets you can actually if
you have legally bought PDFs you can
analyze those you can analyze whatever
kind of textual data you want newspaper
articles are a bunch of fun I used to I
used to use the messaging whatsapp app a
lot back in Asia and Europe so I used to
actually analyze my own textual
conversations which I stab with my
buddies and that was also a lot of fun
and the point of me saying this is that
text analysis one of the huge parts
about why it's interesting is the fact
that you can actually use personal data
to get insights into what your
using it's also really it's you also
used a lot of course in industry by a
lot of people trying to figure out like
advertisements so on and so forth you
can have you have chatbots it's also a
part of text analysis so there's a lot
of generally cool stuff you can do using
text analysis and text so that's why
I'll be talking about that in particular
now the idea again like I talked about
before is breath and not depth so I will
be talking about something called
computational linguistics which is
basically making computers deal with
linguistics so you have things like
parts of speech right like nouns and
verbs and so on how do you write
computer code to identify nouns and
verbs in a sentence and are in
paragraphs and so on that is one part of
what I'll be talking about then there's
topic modeling topic modeling is if you
have lots of large text and it's
completely disorganized how can I find
underlying topics like if it's
newspapers how do I find like a sports
topic a politics topic how can I find
this from text how do I classify text
into different categories I've already
found out for myself like spam or not
spam which everyone hears uses email I'd
suppose so
most people here would be using emails
so you'd have spam or not spam this is
text classification then you also have
text generation which is like what chat
bots are doing here you're kind of
having your conversation or talking so
to say with an algorithm which generates
something resembling human speech so
there's a whole wide spectrum of really
cool things you can do with text
analysis and will actually be very
briefly going to do all the things I
just talked about it's gonna be kind of
fast
that being said questions are totally
welcome and awesome so please keep
stopping me if something is not clear
and well let's get started so what would
be ideal is if everyone had this
particular Jupiter notebook open on
Jupiter but if not then we're just going
to be watching me press shift enter
instead of doing it yourself briefly so
the most the first part about text
analysis usually of course finding your
textual data so that's what we're going
to be starting with I'm going to get my
import set up very briefly going over
the imports we're using or the packages
we're using Jensen is for topic modeling
which is on top numpy numpy
is suppose most people here would know
numpy but it's a way we store our
numbers in using Python in forms of
arrays which are used again in data
analysis a lot you have Spacey which is
a package I really really like which
does industry grade natural language
processing a lot of people when they
think of natural language processing in
Python think of n LT k n LT K is quite
outdated bloated academic code and is
okay for teaching or learning NLP stuff
or computational linguistics but for
anything practical if you want to do
really cool projects or even anything
your space he can actually be used in
your you know production level code so
we want things to be practical so we
will be using Spacey that being said n
LT k can be useful for learning about
natural honors crossing then we have
matplotlib to plot stuff scikit-learn
is a machine learning library which will
be using for classification which i
talked about before this is to just
briefly introduce scikit-learn in the
context of textual analysis and then we
have Kiryas which is a deep learning
library which is a kind of machine
learning where we're going to be dealing
with neural networks and generating text
so these are the libraries we're going
to be using today and I'm just set up
the imports to enemy our warnings and OS
just for some stuff then we're gonna
start with gathering data now I've
talked about earlier why I like textual
analysis because I can get my data from
anywhere and when I started doing this
tutorial I started doing the whole tech
like you know gathering data part I
wrote code to like go on Twitter and
scrape Twitter data which is always
interesting because it's super relevant
right but now the thing is that takes a
lot of time and effort and ended up
becoming a tutorial of its own which I
could not fit into this so well I would
love to talk about it if any if you want
to after this for this tutorial for the
text we will be using a built in data
set which comes with Jennsen called the
lis background corpus
it's basically 300 newspaper articles
from an Australian newspaper
broadcasting agency so the context is
Australian news early 2000 which is not
super exciting but it's very easy to get
so it's what we're gonna be using for
the purposes of this tutorial and
something called a 20 and G data set
with
stands for 20 newsgroups which is
basically a massive newspaper so the
theme is newspaper articles because it's
kind of easy to understand and play with
but what would be ideal is to have some
data which you know would of course
based on either your business model or
whatever or if it's on something
personal it's a lot more fun for the
purpose of this will be using early 2000
newspaper articles and how we're gonna
be getting this data is will the first
three lines of code over here which is
actually on the jensen website we're
basically loading our test data from
where we've installed Jensen so what's
happening over here is doing over starts
up and using the Jensen path will be
basically accessing the data so now our
file which is called text contains all
of our newspaper data now this is a huge
I mean you a cleaning data in general is
a huge huge problem in or no problem or
thing you have to deal with in all kinds
of data analysis but in textual analysis
it kind of becomes even more important
because I mean you again heard this
probably or you should her here about
this when it comes to analysis but
garbage in garbage out if you're gonna
have rubbish data probably gonna get
rubbish results but again what's
important to know is that rubbish or
garbage is very very contextual what is
useful for one person might not be for
the other for example numbers in data
and textual data sometimes you might
want to know what kind of numbers are
coming up in our text sometimes you
don't so sometimes you keep inner
numbers sometimes we don't sometimes you
want to keep in places you don't really
like words on Tuesdays so that day and
just not gonna use words right so
basically there's a lot of different
ways you can clean your data and I'm
gonna and this is a huge part of textual
analysis and I often say that this is
the most important part of the tutorial
the cleaning data part after this it's
you could read the code bit like after
this it's not as this is very very
important it's my point and we will be
using Spacey to do all of this now the
way Spacey works and this is very
important as we go on Spacey has what
you call language models which based on
your language here we'll all be using
English for the purposes Journal but you
also have Spanish German Italian French
as pretty well trained models of
by Spacey but the most popular ones are
in English now what these language
models are are statistically learned
machine learning models which know what
kind of words are herbs in certain
contexts which knows what kind of words
are nouns which knows what kind of words
or numbers and so on and so forth so
Spacey's language models knows what
certain are stop word stop words or
certain words that you use which we
believe don't have information basically
spacy has pre trained models with a lot
of rich linguistic information this is
very very useful when we're cleaning our
texts which are going to be seeing right
now the way you load a language model
after you downloaded which are the
instructions i've given you on the
github page after you download your
language model you would load it by with
this line of code it says NLP is equal
to space it out load en en here is
english for spanish then would be es i
believe and once we will now that NLP
that variable is now our pipeline object
which basically when we can now pass
object pass text through this pipeline
and start annotating our text and doing
cool things with it now i previously
mentioned i said the word stop words but
i did not really go into it i'm gonna
briefly talk about what stop words are
in the context of text analysis because
it's very very important stop words are
words which we which normally don't
provide any extra information during
textual analysis an example of this is
for example if we want to figure out
what kind of topics are coming up in
newspapers which is what we're going to
be seeing in a bit as well the word i or
said or me or has the certain words
don't add much information for example
if you want to know what the topics are
we don't want a like we don't want a
nouns topic or you know what to do with
in in general with pronouns or something
we'd rather have sports or politics or
something which has which gives us more
information
so stop words are words which do not
provide this particular information in
text analysis and we want to get rid of
these words when we're generating our
corpus which we later play with the
corpus is the textual data set we will
be using so in this context
I've already done this experiment once
before and what I found out is that the
word say or saying or variant of the
word say comes up in newspapers a lot
now this is not going to be useful
information in a topic if I don't know
what is being talked about in between
two thousand and thousand and one and I
just get say said mister being I'm like
that's not useful so I know this having
done the experiment once and these words
are not traditionally stop words so I'm
adding these words to my stop word list
in these four lines of code over here
now
spacy already comes with its inbuilt a
list of suggested stop words but usually
based on the context of your problem if
you're dealing with biomedical data for
example and you think one word a protein
or what I mean probably useful but in
the context of your experiment is not
useful you would want to add that word
as not useful or to my stop words list
before starting I've included that here
because later it would just because it
saves time but normally how you figure
out what's not useful is you do the
whole experiment and you look at it like
oh that's not useful and then you come
back up on the new line you add this bit
of code before you start then you start
again but a huge part of textual
analysis is this you never get what do
you want the very first time you kind of
want to do things a whole bunch of times
I know that in the context of newspapers
these are not useful words so I do this
what is going on here is for each
particular stopped word in my list of
stop words I'm using the pipeline and
saying the vocabulary of stop words in
that pipeline make that true so over
here this is actually standard spacy
code this is how Spacey does here a
lexeme is a linguistic unit and each
word is it's just a words to which they
use over here but as you can see we're
basically getting the lexeme which from
the word and then just saying is stop
true yeah it is a stop word so this is
just a small before we actually get
started with what's going to happen what
stop words are is it clear what stop
words are any questions about stop words
or why they're important no okay cool so
now this is very important over here
our sixth line of code I'm doing dark is
equal to NLP of text dot lower
so NLP if you'd remember it just to
Jupiter cells up is Spacey dot loader
contains my English pipeline I am now
passing my document through the spacey
pipeline again what is my document just
to remind you all in the context of this
it's my text which I've opened which is
the newspaper articles so when I run
this over here which is gonna take a
small time but not too long
it's basically annotating every single
word in my corpus which is all those
newspaper articles so it's going to know
in all the newspaper Australian
newspaper articles the details of every
single word in it which are going to see
very briefly here so and I'm gonna show
you what doc is so you can see it says
it's just text just looks like text
right now but none of the people have
been forced to okay their homes in the
southern highlands of New South Wales
are strong winds like a fire and they're
talking about this fire in New South
Wales in the year 2000 and so there's a
lot of different articles and now all of
these which you cannot see right now -
but I'm gonna show really soon all of
this has been annotated by Spacey so now
the dark object has contains information
of every single words is it a stopped
word is it a number what's its part of
speech a whole lot of information this
information starts becoming very useful
a little later especially when you're
cleaning text but in general it is
useful to know when you're doing any
kind of textual analysis you're gonna
see exactly how briefly but this is what
you need to know right now again is
everyone clear what we're doing or why
we're doing what we're doing yeah cool
so now I want all of you didn't remember
that but temporarily we're gonna go out
of context to show you what exactly
computational linguistics is so when I
did that when I basically said document
is equal to NLP of something it
annotated everything now I don't want to
show you all examples based on that
massive text so I'm gonna annotate one
sentence and give examples based on this
uh this particular subfield of text
analysis is called computational
linguistics which is kind of separate
from natural language processing in the
sense that you
more with linguistics or structures of
sentences and language right so we're
not gonna we're gonna now run a sentence
to the same pipeline we ran an entire
corpus the sentence is oh it's Tom enter
here to get some of those delicious
Swedish meatballs and now I'm going to
go over some basic things you can do
with Spacey so the first is part of
speech tagging or pass tagging what
we're gonna do is we're going to now
show you what parts of speech are here
so for token insent
again for contact scent is basically
that particular sentence after it's gone
through the English language pipeline
right so I'm running this over here and
it very very quickly it shows me Tom as
a proper noun when tis a word to Ikea a
proper noun to get some of those
delicious is an adjective Swedish
adjective so you see what's going on
here Spacey now knows what every all the
information in that sentence and gives
us to you Spacey also told you gave you
all this information about that massive
document before right this is just for
this particular sentence so you can go
for every single token here a token is a
single individual linguistic unit of per
sentence and gives you information this
is part of speech tagging there's other
things you can do for example any are
tagging any R stands for named entity
recognition which as it suggests it
looks for specific named entities in our
sentence over here there's only three
named entities one is Tom who's a person
it's IKEA which is an organization and
you have Swedish which over here is so
based on the context this comes up
differently you can a political
organization country place so Spacey has
you have you can go to linguistic
features and look at what exactly so
over here if you look at Spacey in terms
of its named entity recognition
it has geopolitical unit which is GPE so
you have a lot of different kinds of
labels like organization
then you have money as well you have a
lot of different things you can do with
named entities I would recommend
searching it up based on what kind of
named entity you would like to look for
but the common ones are person time
place and so on
you can also here I went over every
token in sentence and I printed the
entity for every token some of them
don't even have them like went and - so
if you want to skip all of that and just
go through entities you can do for and
here enters entity in sentence dot and
and you can look up the only the three
entities which are here you can also
have it Spacey has this really neat
plugin called display C which allows you
to like visualize this in a pretty way
so over here you just have this neat
little purple thing over it so as you
can see Spacey does a lot of cool stuff
part of speech tagging is usually very
useful in general text analysis finding
out entities like this also pretty
useful based on your problem and again
I'd like to make it clear like Spacey
did this for that massive document -
right not just for the sentence now I'm
going to show you what dependency
parsing is which is the idea that in a
sentence things are linked to each other
in a certain way like Tom went to
sweetie so like Tom went is the word so
things going on right so to find out
these dependencies I'm not going to get
into the details of what these
dependencies mean because that's
honestly a lecture on its own like
dependency parsing and parsing of
textual data is a massive subfield of
research I just want to let you all know
this exists and Spacey does this for you
an easy
so this basically shows you the
structure again if you're more
interested in dependency parsing I would
recommend searching up how Spacey does
it but to give you an idea of the kind
of information it's basically this so
it's like here the root of the sentence
is normally the word for spacey so you
have went being it links you know Tom
and so you can see that this is what
Spacey does it gives prepositions and
subject/object it basically tells you
how a sentence sentence is structured
right you can get all this kind of
information using display CN space
and this is done sentence by sentence
for every single sentence which is why
that took a little bit of time before
and we were analyzing her dock so any
art post tagging any art tagging and
dependency parsing tend to be three of
the most important computational
linguistic ideas which are normally
talked about are discussed so is
everyone here clear with what these
three are more or less yeah awesome so
you can I would really recommend getting
into you also have this for Spanish
French German as well and Spacey is open
source of course and it's always
updating its models to make them better
they're all neural networks under the
hood by the way for those who are
interested it's a it's a deep learning
network which is trained to find out
what exactly you would tag something on
as you can also train your own taggers
so if you want to have like your own
particular label or you know part of
speech whatever you can perth you can
train space these models with your own
data so there's a lot of really cool
things you can do over here in the
computational linguistics part of Spacey
now we're gonna so that was a small
detour just to let you all know what
Spacey can do if you remember the last
thing which we had done before we took
our detour is this dock object which
basically has Alden Australian newspaper
articles right so now let's go back to
cleaning this because there's still some
kind of information which might not be
useful to us so now this is very
important when the in there in the
context of so what we did before this
was computational linguistics now we're
slowly moving out of that realm into the
machine learning part of this and
machine learning it means what's very
important is electors now the reason why
vectors are important is machines don't
understand words so we need to represent
them as numbers and numbers when there's
a lot of them and in text we have a lot
of numbers because so I'm gonna take
again a small detour so I'm going to try
and explain to you how machines
understand
in terms of data structures right there
are many ways now let's assume that uh
again this these are hypothetical
numbers but they would be kind of close
maybe if we're gonna to look at a
newspaper corpus I can actually just
look at the length of the dictionary in
a bit but let's talk about let's assume
that this all the newspaper articles
which we have the three or newspaper
articles if you look at all the
different kinds of unique words being
used in them let's just say there are
10,000 words right so like all of the
articles in these newspapers are only
made from this vocabulary of 10,000
words normally of course it's gonna be a
lot more words but in the context of
every machine layer I mean every text
analysis project we do there's always a
vocabulary which is every unique word
being used in your analysis now how does
a computer figure out what's in a
document it basically has this really
really massive like indexing of every
single word so if it's Tom it would be
like you know index zero and then you'd
have every word is index one running up
to index 10,000 in vocabulary for each
word right and then if you have a
document which could be even a sentence
is a it could be a document or whatever
it would basically have a 0 or a 1 based
on if that particular word exists in
that document so you'd represent a
document and a real like each document
even if it has three words would say
nine thousand nine hundred ninety seven
zeroes and three ones but you're still
using up all of that data right I mean
you're using up all that space so this
is why we have to be really careful in
our in the in the best possible way we
can give information to our models right
so I'm gonna be now talking about how we
create our lists or list lists of lists
to demin to allow computers to actually
use this textual data now if all this
sounds a little complicated become a lot
more clear once I run these I'm going to
first just run this oh this is a super
important cell by the way cell number
sixteen is very very important because
it's going to tell you how you're going
to create your data structure which is
going to be your input for most machine
learning algorithms so this is the part
let's go through this really slowly so
first I create
two lists one is called text someone
it's called article text is basically
going to be our entire data set or all
our texts an article is going to be each
individual article so for W in doc doc
again I would like to remind you it was
that massive document and W is every
single word or token so for W in doc if
the text or if the contents of that word
is not a newline is not a stop word is
not punctuation and it's not a number I
like that particular word to be appended
to my article is that clear that's
basically this over here what I'm hot so
the reason I'm doing this is because
when I want to create for example which
I'm going to show you in a small bit
topic models or any kind of large
statistical models I don't want stop
words I know that I don't want a new
line because a new line in my dataset
represents a new article so I want to
keep it to one article one article if
it's not a stop word if it's not
punctuation like a full stop or a comma
is not going to give me a lot of
information about this particular topic
right and if it's not a number because
in my context I don't want numbers you
all could totally keep numbers if you'd
like if I have and you could add more
rules if you're trying to create a
database of only like I talked about
before like only words you could search
for words and only put in words
so what Spacey does is Spacey's now
allows you to have is punked like number
or not and for example if you want to do
find out what a verb is I've talked
about this briefly earlier where it's
token dot POS underscore where you would
have were bort so you can choose what
you want to keep in your corpus I've
decided to keep everything which is not
a stop word everything which is not a
number everything which is not
punctuation or a newline as part of my
corpus and then after that I've said
every time I do see a newline I want to
add that particular article to my text
right so that's what's going on over
here
to be clear what now our things look
like this is very important what I've
done is I've gone from this
over here right which is hundreds of
people have been forced to okay their
homes bah-bah-bah
- over this where instead of hundreds of
people have been forced to locate it's
this hundred people forced verkaik home
can you see what's happening over here
this is very important cell 16 and 17
are very important because they talk
about what cleaning textual data is so
remember what we've done before this all
the cells about this you remember what I
had which is just like massive documents
which been annotated and I've gone from
that to this list of lists where each
sub like each list within this list is
an article and each list contains all
the words which I think are useful so
over here I got rid of like hundred of
hundreds of people you're seeing what's
going on here right this is a very
important part of text analysis and it's
how computers are gonna get anything
meaningful out of what you say so is
this like a 10,000 percent clear with
everyone here no hands up cool I'm going
on because this is very important and
the bit and the rest of the talk
sort of builds on this so it's important
that this is clear so just to make
things even more clear this would be
only our first document this would be
only the hundred first document and if
you'd want what is like I don't even
know if there's the seventh word in this
document which is important to us as
custody must be someone's so yeah so
this is to give you an idea of the kind
of data structure we have what is the
size of this data sorry about that
so it's 299 which is 300 so this is just
to give you an idea of the data set we
are creating right now we're gonna move
on and I'm gonna give you a little bit
more information about the fancy kind of
things we can do when we're cleaning up
our documents so we're going to
introduce a topic called by grams by
grams or I mean it's engrams I'm going
to be specifically talking about by
grams and grams are basically you might
have noticed over earlier on when I
looked at text right
just to give you an example I'm like
this is a really quick example you can
see New South Wales
right these are three different words in
my previous document but a New South
Wales I believe is a territory in
southern Australia and so now what's
gonna what's gonna happen over here is
New South Wales is three separate words
but in our text analysis it kind of
would make more sense if it's one word
right because it means the same thing if
we see New York coming up again and
again and again we know it's we'd know
that we'd want to rather deal with New
York instead of new and York and the
same for Los Angeles and so basically
any place where two words appear around
each other so often they make more sense
as one word than two words then we'd
want to do something called bigram
generation and we can use bigram
we can create diagrams with the jensen
you could also totally code up all of
these things on your own by the way i'm
these packages just makes things faster
right
so by grams in the context of jensen
which is the first machine learning
package we'll be using we're going to be
loading it using jensen model short
phrases and texts so we are basically
passing all our text through this model
and I'm creating a bigram model I'm
gonna now do the diagram part it's
basically apply my bigram
on line for every line in texts right so
I'm this is all I'm creating my text of
diagrams let's see what looks like you
can see over here in New South as now
has an underscore over there it's new
underscore South so this is what
happened in that one line every instance
of New South Wales or it goes to that
particular corpus for the context of
that corpus do certain words appear
around each other if they do let's make
it one word now of course this doesn't
mean that every time there's a new the
next word gets appended right it only
means for this particular context it
gets appended so it you have different
results based on what you're going to be
doing a rural fire and fire burn also
got picked up over here by the way so
there is a level of how much you want to
be able to do this if you want to make
sure it's not picking up every word or
what extent of it you'd have to go into
the phrases module and play with the
parameters which I'm going to leave all
it's an exercise because you don't know
the time to do that but based on your
context this can be very very useful
also rural fire an urban fire of the
different things could also be useful
if these words are coming up together a
lot maybe they do mean something so this
is to introduce the idea of by grams in
text analysis sure oh yeah totally so
like that the question was would it be
would it be worth doing unnamed entity
recognition on then running a bigram to
make sure only caching named entities
yeah totally that would be a good way to
do it so that you're making sure that
things like rule fire not accidentally
picked up so you could maybe you could
run a bigram by you could tag things as
places and then make sure a bigram only
does those places and go on and do it so
that is definitely a way you can go
about doing things now we sort remember
that in the end even though we now how
our data said you know more cleaned up
organized way with no stop words and
some cool things put together it's still
words right and computers don't get
words so what we're gonna be doing right
now is converting words to numbers and
we're gonna be used doing a dictionary
to do this now a dictionary is a Python
object dictionary but in this particular
context it's a Jensen Python object
called dictionary which basically sets
it up easier for you to do things but
the idea remains the same every word
gets an ID right so we're gonna be
creating this dictionary using
dictionary over here is a Jensen module
so dictionary is equal to dictionary of
text so you're creating your dictionary
from texts and you're creating your
corpus in text analysis talk corpus
basically means your data set it's just
another word for textual data you just
call it corpus in the context of any
kind of textual analysis or even in the
context of research if you have like a
corpus of historical Renaissance data
the word is corpus this word comes up a
lot in things you might be searching up
later so I'm gonna run this and I'm
gonna briefly show you what Dictionary
is so it's a Jennsen object but you also
you basically the index for 0 is near
and so on and so forth so you have based
on based on the word you have a
different
and that's what dictionary is and not
what we're going to be doing is let's
check out the length of our dictionary
so there's 5329 unique words being used
this is after we got rid of our stop
words and a whole bunch of stuff and
after we combined words together and
everything so you'd probably have a lot
more before you do the cleaning which we
did together sure no no no no yeah I
should have made that clear
so just to be absolutely clear with that
that's why we did dictionary is equal to
dictionary of texts here right and text
if you remember is just this massive
list over here which is all my newspaper
articles right is that clear so texts
are all my newspaper articles and
dictionary of texts is basically the
dictionary of all the work the newspaper
articles which is all the unique words
used there but this is after we did the
cleaning right so no stop words I'm
gonna show you right now so corpus would
have you detects the code says corpus is
dictionary dot doc - bow now I should
probably explain that before that I'm
gonna tell you what bow is bow is bag of
words so what's been happening over here
before if you had a document like any
kind of document it would just be 0 or 1
based on the word being there not being
there but again that takes up a lot of
space what if instead we can do it's
probably gonna be easier if I just run
the code basically a corpus of 0 this is
what text has become has become this 0
comma 1 1 comma 1 to Comic Con what does
this mean now this basically means that
the 0 @ word appeared once the first
word appeared once and the third word
appeared twice and the twenty first word
appeared three times can you see what's
going on so the twenty first word is
yes the 21st word in the dictionary is
rain so in that particular document the
word rain has a period price now the
reason we're doing this is because
otherwise we would have this whole
massive 10,000 word array with every
single is it there or not and we still
like so we want to compress that so it's
called a bag of words because each of
these 0 each of the indexes is like a
bag and we're like counting words so
that's what's going on over here this is
just an easier way for the computer to
deal with the sparse data a sparse
vector so that is what corpus and what
is the code for that dictionary dot doc
to bow so document to bag of words of
text for each text in texts so again I'd
like to you could actually build this
dictionary yourself by you know it's not
super fancy Python code right like just
I'd rate through all your documents it's
just a kind of a pain to do it
Jennsen is specifically for text
analysis and does it for you to be clear
scikit-learn also does it spacey like
any kind of python text analysis library
is gonna have these functions in it but
I'm kind of breaking it down so you can
also do the code yourself but it's
optimized it's fast it's easy and
dictionary document to backwards for
text so is that clear what we went to
from where like we had this just raw
text to clean draw text to list of lists
of raw text to bigram of raw text and
now to a bag of words of raw text and
because this is kind of our final form
of cleaning for our analysis I'm gonna
call it corpus because that's just what
we normally call in this particular
field so everyone up to speed over here
at this point awesome ok so now we're
going to start with so until now we so
it's it's 1147 which means it's been 47
minutes 37 it's more or less of only
cleaning text the reason I've spent so
much time is because it's extremely
extremely important you cannot even if
you know all of these fancy machine
learning methods after this it's
pointless you're not gonna get anything
interesting or useful if you're not
going to be very very diligent with your
text cleaning
so it's important to know what you can
possibly do why you're doing what you
can possibly do and having a sort of
idea this is not the only these are not
the only things you can do there's a lot
people get into more detail and you can
get for example you can get rid of words
which are not frequent like if a certain
word it's just that it's turning up once
in one document you're like yo yo why do
I even need that word right so you get
rid of that and you can keep five or ten
or whatever number you want as your
minimum frequency cutoff you can keep a
maximum if the same words operating in
literally every document is it
information so to say so you can get rid
of the most frequent words the least
frequent words you can do all of these
things these are also things done in
text cleaning I'm not doing them because
it's not necessary but you can totally
do it there's a lot of ways to go about
doing this this is my way of going about
doing this particular way you get
different kinds of results but it's
heavily contextual right based on your
business problem or whatever personal
project you're working on you'll be
having a different cleaning process
these are the kind of stuff which
everyone does how one thing to mention
which I actually forgot to talk about
over here this is the super important
one number 16 that sells talking about
right
I said article that append is equal to W
dot lemma right and lemma is not text
and I've written on top we add the lemma
type version of the word is a comment
over here I forgot to talk about what
limit ization is it's a very important
part of text analysis basically the word
saying said and say for example all of
them have the root word say right or
like writing wrote write all of these
are the same root word so if this word
appears in different like because of the
function of the kind of word is it
appears in different forms in my text it
all means the same thing if I want to
and if I want to capture that original
root word that's called a lemma and this
form of getting the root word is called
lemma ties ation so for some words the
word itself is the lemma right but for
any other words like saying will become
say and say is also say but both of
these represent the same word it's
called limit ization I would recommend
you can do it really quick Google for a
limited station if you want to read
about it there's another concept called
step
another concept called stemming where
you just kind of hack off the last part
of the word so like everything but then
it looks kind of ugly and it's not very
pretty so I prefer to use lament ization
but you could also use stemming stemming
and limit ization or two ways in which
we basically if there are a lot of words
which could mean the same thing but are
just different forms of the word we want
to just use that base form that process
is called dilemma ties ation I've also
only added the lemma ties forms of the
words this gives better results though
that being said you could also not do
this it's really up to you but this is a
very important part which I missed out
on so it's the lemma unlimited a ssin
which also Spacey's got like when it did
it told doctor analysis it did lemma as
well so like a specie are not paying me
by the way I really just like them so
we're gonna start with topic modeling
now which is the first machine learning
part of this tutorial right so I briefly
talked about topic modeling before very
briefly I said that if I have a
newspaper corpus that you haven't have
this is in a context of Australian
Southern whatever but let's just say
very broadly if I have a lot of textual
data and I want to classify this and I
have no information whatsoever a topic
model is a really nice way to get a
cursory glance at my documents for
example if I feed in 10,000 newspaper
articles I can end up and I say four
topics or three topics or something like
that I can end up getting three topics
which would be sports which would have
football soccer basketball baseball so
on and maybe some names and politics and
you'd have certain names associated
politics and whether it should be sunny
beach so you know or I'm from Chicago so
rain cold miserable so you'd have things
like this based on your newspaper
articles which you're actually dealing
with now we're gonna find out exact so
the way it does this is it's called
latent direct allocation it's the name
of the algorithm this is the name of the
most popular one there are multiple
topic modeling algorithms that you can
use but it's called latent direct
allocation because latent because these
topics are not clear to us immediately
their latent topics hidden under the
text so to say derelict is a kind of
probabilistic distribution which is how
it does it which is
it's kind of Bayesian inference to kind
of say it's a statistical modeling
algorithm where it looks at what kind of
words appear around each other with what
probabilities and it kind of does an
analysis of trying to find topics of
words and documents which come together
topic modeling in itself is a you know
huge research field I've done a few
tutorials on topic modeling before which
you can search up if you're interested
or you can just talk to me after this
but I'm gonna very briefly go through
what it is rough idea massive unordered
unclassified texts now you have topics
after which you can choose to classify
or not classified but these topic models
are useful in general right so what am I
so I'm going to be the import here is LD
a model which you can see over here
which is from Jensen which you if you
check the imports you would find it over
there what are my inputs or the
parameters over here corpus is the
corpus if you just created number of top
extent so you have to specify write the
number of topics you want this is very
important it's not gonna find out the
number of topics on its own there are
certain algorithms which attempt to do
this but really it's if you should have
a very rough idea alternatively you can
just run like seven hey this looks this
makes sense eight this doesn't and you
can figure it out there are more
quantitative methods to find out the
number of topics but that's like a whole
again field on its own I've written
tutorials about that in the same
repository which you can actually search
up since you don't have this repository
I get more into topic modeling but the
idea is you need to tell the number of
topics in one right so number of topics
is ten and ID - word is dictionary over
here it basically means ID - word which
is a dictionary but you can put in a
jensen dictionary object you can also
put in any dictionary which has ids and
words but the idea is zero - whatever
and the reason again is because when you
print your topics it needs to have an ID
- word mapping so it's just for the
Jenson to know what's going on right any
questions before that no okay cool so
I'm gonna run this it's not a super
massive corpus right it's only 300
documents and normally like that's tiny
data in the context of data analysis
normally you're dealing with thousands
of documents but for the purpose of
storoe but you know it's still a
reasonable number so I'd like to make it
very clear more than a more documents
you have the
more fleshed out your topics are going
to look right 300 documents is not
enough to have really beautiful topics
come up but to represent some kind of
complexity but that being said let's see
what kind of topics we have okay people
de Australia Australian on this an
Australian day maybe and Adelaide
airline then you have your company then
you have something with a poly bond
Australian kill force company pellets
three 2001 was not well yeah so you have
these are the topics which you Sierra so
you can see there's a kind of a theme
going on there's something government
Pakistan India attack force so well
there's a bunch of different topics you
can really fine-tune this is ten I could
totally do like five run this again in
the meantime you can just have a look
tell you what this looked like zero is
topic zero topic one topic two so also
the topic which I have called like the
weather topic or the sports topic it
won't exist but it won't have a title
you have to give each topic or title of
your own a topic is a probabilistic
distribution of words right so it's like
these words are going to appear in this
topic with that the odds of these words
are putting the topic are more so I'm
just gonna show you with five topics
what it looks like maybe it's a bit
better people police tech force one in
Australia so you can see we're here
maybe Australia is not a very important
word because it's an Australian
newspaper corpus we don't maybe need
that you could then add that and your
stop words remove it and do it again and
then you'd see a results right you can
see China it's a heavily I creative
process of finding out your ideal topics
again I would my topic modeling tutorial
the same repository goes into more
details on getting better topic models
right this is just to give you an idea
of what they look like and what you can
do also based on your data said they
will be it'll be very useful or not
useful at all it's kind of hit and miss
but I find it very useful in exploring
large textual data sets you could also
find out the percentage of each topic in
different documents it's it's just a
useful model of your textual data if
it's unclassified in my opinion
yeah that's a very good question now
I've actually so I did mention about how
I do have a topic modeling tutorial
which I'm going to briefly open but not
get into
it's called topic modeling so over here
I actually talked about how to find the
number of topics in and well one way
which I'm going to very very briefly get
into something called topic coherence
which is a quantitative way to tell you
how good or bad your topic is so what
you would do is you would run your topic
model 4 7 8 9 10 or 10 15 20 whatever
you know whatever you think might be the
number of topics check out the topic
coherence values for each of these
topics for a number of topics and then
choose the best number but the other way
is it's a really tough question you can
there are different there are different
ways you can find out how good a topic
model is but in the end it really comes
down to this looks kind of right you
know but that being said there are a few
quantitative ways topic coherence is one
of these ways there's also a bunch of
pretty graphs and plots which make you
allow you to kind of figure out you know
like for example one way is this is one
way you can see over here this is not in
this tutorial but a different one which
you can see you can see a lot of these
these are all topics by the way this is
a visualization of topics you can see
that a lot of these topics are
clustering together so hey why not just
have one topic instead of all of those
right so these are ways you can try and
do figure out what does optimize your
topic models so to say but we're not
gonna be getting into that it is super
interesting still I think just to be
able to find out what kind of topics are
in your text with like no prior
information to be clear we there was no
classification going on over here we
gave no information we just threw like a
bunch of text and it said this is useful
information which i think is very very
cool so I'm a big fan of topic models
and I think they're really useful and
interesting yeah
it is the probability of that word
appearing in that topic we only show the
top 10 I believe it's 10 you can choose
that by the way gentle eyes really
choose the number of top words and a
topic you want to display in this case
it basically says for these five topics
these are the ten most probable words to
appear in that topic so these words tend
to make tend to aggregate over here you
see now as you'd go on you'd have
obviously like the probability gets
lower and lower and lower and also this
probability is shared between five
thousand two hundred thirty nine words
right so you may argue old 0.004 is so
tiny but it's not in the context right
so you don't so have more interesting
results a larger data set and Jenson is
a really neat package which does a lot
of different kinds of topic models this
is not the only kind there's a lot of
different kinds of topic models by the
way yeah sure sure so I think in this
particular case in this kind of stemming
I think because it's a proper noun it's
ignored that would be my guess
right yeah that would that would be my
guest normally this would be caught
though then that's a good point
again like all of these kinds of things
like I reach it every time I do like a
where end of this tutorial or this
tutorial
people point out that hey this is kind
of and that happened that's and that's
awesome that just goes to kind of prove
my point that you need to do multiple
iterations to get very useful results
the the text cleaning part like a lot of
the text cleaning happens after you
finish the project right because you're
doing in the second time to get better
results so that's a something we would
you point it out yes Australia and
Australian you'd argue that it might not
be standing or something so what I would
do is I would tell my Spacey model which
you which on the spacey website you can
see how you do this right you can tell
the model to key make exceptions and
cast these things and fine-tune your
stuff but yeah that that's a good point
so is everyone kind of clear with what
topic models are there more questions
about topic models
I wouldn't mind talking about topic
marks a little bit more but you could
also this other tutorials in the same
repository you can get more details
about but that's the general idea of
topic models and these are one of the
things you can do with text now I'm
gonna move on to text classification so
now we're going to stop using yeah oh
that's a very good question so the
question is how are you preserving the
context of the words when you're
converting into bag of words you are not
you are throwing context out the window
that's a hundred percent
so there are depending on what you so
the thing about topic modeling right for
example or text classification we don't
care so much so about the con about the
context of the words as we care about
the presence of these words like in spam
and not spam like a popular thing like
if you have like lottery prize winner so
on and so forth just that the words that
they exist is a big giveaway it's not
the most sophisticated way because
you're certainly losing context a
hundred percent and if you want even
better classification which has context
or ways there's something called word to
Eck which is a way you preserve context
which is also really popular using text
analysis I might briefly talk about it
later and not if you have the time so
there are methods you can use to
preserve context it really depends on
the kind of project your problem you
want to solve but yeah
badda words and even this original way
it only lets you know if that word
exists in that document if you want to
know the way sentences are structured
semantic meaning or contextual
understanding you have more more
interesting machine learning algorithms
which allow you to do this and I will I
will actually be very briefly talking
about them and they are now leading the
forefront of textural classification all
these things are done using these
context based models which capture this
but for the longest time we didn't have
context 2000 for 13 or 15 was when were
to ik came up I mean people are trying
to solve this context problem for a
while the most sophisticated way was
worth to act which is done by some folks
over at Google where they tried to
capture this context which you talk
about and you can later do this as well
but for this talk we're going to be
sticking to this but that is a very good
question
if you have more to you should
definitely read about it if talk to me
about it after this I would love to yeah
yeah I'll eat awake is super cool yeah
yeah it's rabies and some Jensen we're
trying to get that into their package as
well though I totally dig guiltier to
like it's awesome but that's so these
are other statistical learning
algorithms which also use topic models
as part of this context I mean there's a
lot of things and the whole point of
this tutorial is to also just kind of
introduce everyone to that which and
then you can go into more details if
you'd like so I will talk about all of
this towards the end but now I'm gonna
move on to text classification are there
any other questions before that that it
okay cool so um so far we worked with
unlabeled unstructured data right like
we got the data dump of newspaper
articles there was no no we didn't know
what it was gonna be about I mean I knew
because I saw it but the computer had no
clue about what its gonna be about now
we're gonna be dealing with data which
is already classified when you know for
example I mean there's an interesting
project which I was trying to work on
before with a bunch of people back at my
university where we're looking at if we
can predict if someone has early signs
of depression based on looking at the
social media post and this is a
practical example right excellence is
super handy right so I had data where I
I knew where certain updates or posts
were like the rank does how depressive
they are so to say and based on that I
was supposed to tell how the press or a
non depressive other social media posts
again this is just one context it could
be literally anything right so in this
case we classified data before or we
annotate our data before annotating or
classifying basically annotating
actually basically means when you're
part of speech tagging is also part of a
kind of annotation it's when you tell
your data what it is before you do any
kind of classification task when you
mark it label or annotate it the
computer knows the your machine learning
algorithm knows what kind of data labels
are dealing with it's just also called
labeling your data so we're gonna be
looking at now problems where we have
labels on our data and most usually when
you're lucky you have some kind of
labels you want to get a percentage of
accuracy
so this is called classification
problems are supervised learning
supervised because you're giving labels
or annotations what we did before was
unsupervised because we didn't really
apart from the number of topics but it's
still called unsupervised and this is
called supervised now I'm gonna be going
over this part a lot faster because it's
the idea it's just again let you know
what's available right if you want me to
slow down though please let me know and
I will go slow but it's also the last 25
minutes I'm gonna kind of up the pace
over here so a bunch of imports over
here all these imports are to get our
data set ready and we're gonna be using
psychic learn now and we're gonna moving
on I'm moving away from Jensen and going
to psychic learn because cyclin is very
popular in machine learning and I and in
and it also has a lot of cool tech stuff
we just want I want to introduce
everyone to so I'm gonna do some things
for feature extraction or just tf-idf
echo blah blah bunch of imports
basically a lot of imports but we need
these and I will explain why now what
I'm going to be doing in this particular
cell is data transformations and getting
my data now what I talked about we're
gonna be also switching datasets so
we're going out of our Australian
newspaper corpus right so now it's gonna
be gonna be using something called a 20
ng dataset or 20 newsgroups data set
there are 20 categories we're only gonna
be using 4 of these 20 categories which
are these are random but two of them are
about religion one is on graphics one a
space I just picked the first floor I
think so we're not going to be doing
classification for all 20 we're gonna be
doing four that's again for the for this
particular example you would have
complex tasks with 20 or even more
labels for this one we're just using
four because it's faster so data train
so in these kind of cases you have a you
are training a model which you are then
using to predict right that's a kind of
different different kind of paradigm
than what we dealt with before
previously we're just you know kind of
getting information about our data now
we're gonna actually train a machine
learning model based on what we saw and
classify into a particular class based
on that model
if any of these words are not making
sense stop me but I will explain them
you know in a wee bit so you have data
train which which is a variable so fetch
20 new scopes basically fresh this data
it's just a function of my psychic learn
the subset is only trained so I'm only
getting my training data training data
is labeled data right that's very
important any kind of data which are
using to train a model on is like
already has labels or annotations we're
gonna be learning from these annotations
and this data to make new predictions or
new labels for unseen documents so now
the other thing so I people see talked
about bag of words right and that's one
way to represent your textual data now
we're gonna be that was also kind of
manual where we kind of created that
using Jennsen now I'm gonna show you our
scikit-learn does this so now I'm going
to say I don't want bag of words I want
to make it even more sparse I want to
use five in this case five I mean some
just chose five it could be anything
right so again we have a vocabulary the
last case was five thousand three and
something this time would probably be
around that as well I don't want to use
the entire vocabulary I want to train it
on a smaller part of it so I'm gonna
here the number of components is five
and I am training I'm basically
transforming my data now what does this
mean
previously we also did this actually we
did when we transform the data from our
raw textual data to our bag of words and
this part what I what I showed you
before
now we're gonna be transforming our data
into something called tf-idf which
stands for term frequency inverse
document frequency is what it stands for
the idea is you want to get words which
are appearing a whole lot of times in a
lot of documents but not in every
document so it's called inverse document
I'm not going to get into the math part
of it right now if you are interested it
again like you can search it up it's
really popular in text analysis term
it's basically like Baga words it's a
way of representing your textual data so
that's where you have tf-idf vectorizer
training on transforming now even after
I do this there's still a lot of words
in my vocabulary so I want now what I
want to do is I want to reduce the
number of dimensions there's a lot of
ways you can reduce the number of
dimension
of something this just means 10,000
dimensions over here I want to reduce
that to four or five or something which
is easier for a computer to understand
here that's SVD or it's called so SVD is
basically a vector decomposition
singular vector it's so it's it's a kind
of decomposition where you have a
massive maîtrise now all of these when
you have a lot of documents becomes a
really massive matrix matrix right when
you want to reduce this to a small
number of dimensions use different kinds
of machine learning or linear algebra
methods to do this one ways SVD so SVD
so these are again I'm just want to
introduce you all to different ways in
which you can normalize your data or
basically make a huge vocabulary smaller
so what we're doing now is we are so
LFA's latent semantic analysis all of
these are basically the idea is have a
lot of words a lot of words are not
going to be kind of complicated in
classification so let's lower our
dimensions into something we can use
better and in this case it's tf-idf and
SVD I also want to just kind of throw a
lot of words at you all so you can later
go and google it and then be like wow I
learned all this cool stuff and but the
idea is to lower your number of
dimensions that is the core idea of this
the reason why we do it is again like I
talked about before these are a lot of
dimensions here dimensions is the
features dimensions are basically the
number of things you are using to do
make a prediction or train a model right
now I'm doing the same thing but I'm
doing it from my testing data before
this it was my training data remember we
have classification now which means it's
supervisors means we have training and
testing and things like this which we
did not have before with topic models so
we train our did we create our model by
training on certain kind of data and
then we see how good this model is by
testing it on test data right so you can
see over here like so scikit-learn
offers i'm sorry didn't run this panic
there prove it there we go so that
happened really fast also scikit-learn
offers really nice tutorials on what
exactly is going on within this it's out
of the context for me to talk
out of the context of the stroll for me
to talk about how exactly the data
reduction a dimension reduction is going
on I would really recommend googling it
and finding out more about it because
it's a pretty important idea but since
we're sticking to text analysis I'm
going to move on so now we created our
training our testing set again these two
cells have a lot of code take your time
to go through it in the documentation
later so you know what exactly is going
on what you need to know is a lot of
dimensions last dimensions data's not
ready so what exactly are we doing there
are many different kinds of machine
learning algorithms which we can use to
classify data what we use before topic
models are also a suite of probabilistic
or machine learning models but that was
not classification classification like I
said before you know a label you make a
prediction like the spam and not spam
thing even from spam and not spam the
earliest spam identification models were
usually something called Gaussian naive
Bayes which is basically a
classification it's a classification
algorithm where it looks at oh these
kind of words end up appearing in a lot
of males which have spam so these kind
of words are probably more spammy
keywords so that's how it does it under
the hood right in a probabilistic manner
by looking at each word and adjusting
these probabilities
we're just gonna do import Gaussian and
B which makes your life a lot easier and
we train these models now I've done GNB
's equal to Gaussian and B which is our
model then I've done Gen B dot fit X
train Y train dot predict what exactly
is going on I am fitting my model I this
could also be in two lines I'm just
doing it in one line over here but I'm
fitting my model using my X train and
why train X train is my data Y train is
the label for the data I've talked about
labels before and now I'm pretty once I
fit my model here fit is training I'm
not creating my model and once I'm done
training or fitting my model it's fit
because it fits it according to the
probabilistic and then after that it's
predict which means I'm making a
prediction on X test which is my testing
data so Y pred and B would be the
prediction which my machine learning
model has made on the test data and you
can see it's a 0 3 and why does it say
that it basically says okay let's just
look at the first document
the first document was which in the text
in our text test sorry in our test data
was classified into class zero do you
see so based on the contents of what was
our first test well it was placed over
there and three is our fourth class and
the twenty-second document was put in
our fourth class and so on and so forth
so now what you've done is you have X
test which is all of your testing data
which we didn't know what class this was
right we are now using this model to
classify this test data into one of
these four classes which is what has
happened over here classification is not
limited to only text by the way the same
methods i've used before like tf-idf is
particularly for text because its term
frequency but there's you also do image
classification right that's like a super
common task where you have handwritten
like your handwriting from 0 to 9 and
you want to see every single handwritten
0 to 9 if what what does a computer call
it that's also classification it's just
the labels and classes are different in
a different context but classification
is a generic machine learning problem in
the context of text classification what
just happened was I had a document which
is either about atheism religion
graphics or space and it was classified
into one of these four based on the
contents of that document right everyone
cool in classification more or less so
here we use cycle and you do it cyclic
learned has pretty much the same kind of
pipeline for all classification tasks so
this kind of teaches you are to do
classification for other contexts as
well but in text you'd use tf-idf and
all these things over here so Jensen and
scikit-learn are kind of different in
that context of the kind of problems you
want to solve and the way you want to do
it but they're both fairly easy and you
know you can kind of use the same corpus
in both places it's pretty cool
SVC is something called support vector
classifier classifier where support
vectors support vector machines are
another kind of machine learning
algorithm where you try to create a
plane instead of classifying by a line
use a plane instead yeah
so I'd actually have to be absolutely
honest that so the question is basically
how does the scikit-learn tf-idf
vectorizer find the term frequencies for
all the documents correct so I'm not
sure how scikit-learn does this under
the hood I would have to go and
double-check and then maybe we can like
look at it later I'm not sure I'm not
actually I'm sorry does it under the
hood but it does seem through the job
because this particular module right is
for text analysis like the tf-idf part
so the way they've set it up is such
that it takes care of this but I'm not
sure exactly how I'd have to look at the
code or look at the parameters and see
what's going on but it's a good thing
you pointed out because you can also
look at the other parameters which are
part of that which says stop words is
English we did the stop words bit a bit
more manually before here scikit-learn
does the stop words as part of it but
also means you cannot player out of the
stop words as much so there's like a
there's certain levels I'll use IDF true
or false then the maximum document
frequency minimum so these are all these
are the standard values which I picked
up off scikit-learn you can really play
around with it again to be clear tf-idf
term frequency and risk document
frequency different way of representing
or textual documents similar to bag of
words that you used before but a little
more nuanced and you don't have to use
it it's just useful and you can do cool
things with it and represent data better
of transfer questions particular we'd
have to go over the scikit-learn
documentation figure it out I don't want
to give a wrong answer which I'm not
100% sure about but we can definitely
talk about it cool so we are at the last
part of the tutorial I will be going
over this part a little faster because
there are 12 minutes left and I want to
give at least five
- seven minutes for questions if we
don't have questions then I can you know
do this in more detail but I'm going to
go really fast into this so deep
learning is a subfield of machine
learning I don't think I really
introduced what machine learning is
machine learning is basically a lot of
data then you put it inside if that
usually statistical or a nitrito
algorithm which learns from data and
makes prediction that is a general idea
which we've been doing before this as
well right so deep learning deep
learning is it's called deep learning
because we use something called deep
neural networks there's also something
called shallow learning by the way when
we just use like a neural network just
one or two layers the reason it's called
deep is because you use multiple layers
the more layers you have the deeper your
network is and in general deep learning
largely come I mean let all these kinds
of neural networks which have over like
an arbitrary number of networks like
eight you would say layers would all be
deep learning networks pardon me there
are many kinds of deep learning networks
or neural networks in general there are
a lot of different kinds of neural
networks neural networks are kind of
like they are a mathematical construct
which is kind of modeled after a human
human brain more or less in the way it
passes information between different
nodes I will not get into details of
what a neural network is because I can
that is like a huge talk of its own
what do you would know is these are more
powerful computationally intensive class
of machine learning algorithms which are
loosely modeled on the biological brain
is a very brief idea of what they are
there are many different kinds of neural
networks what we will be using is
something called recurrent neural
networks which are kind of like stacked
in a way where the data is recurrent and
in particular we'll be using something
called LS TM which stands for long
short-term memory which is a way because
memory is important because you have to
remember contexts I'm gonna ask me about
context before so neural networks are
really good at capturing context we
someone also mentioned LD a to wek which
stands for LD a - vector or word -
vector these are all things I've said
before all of these are really useful in
understanding context because they have
memory so to say in terms of how they
learn these
so they're more sophisticated more
intensive and really cool actually I've
put up a lot of links over here and I
would really really recommend reading
these links because it's an excellent
blog post over there these two links I
would also any word you don't understand
in this tutorial just google it there's
a lot of really nice resources or mail
me or isn't issue on my repository and I
could direct you to some interesting
reading material about these things now
what we're going to be using is this
machine learning model to learn text the
way it happens I'm gonna kind of be a
little fast about this but the general
idea is it this neural network learns
based on the context of one particular
character what is the most likely
character on either side now you extend
this to words and so on and so forth
so what does this mean it means I am
most likely this like personally I am
most likely if I'm going to be talking
about myself for example like in this
context I would say I would start a
scent insert I write
so neural network start starts to learn
these things then you start sentence
with I or he or she or they or whatever
it lands these things and it learns
after a particular word what is the most
likely like after deep I'm probably
gonna have fried after that I mean it is
gonna learn different kinds of things
based on the context based on the data
your training it on it could be
drastically different but what it learns
is what is the most likely character or
word after this particular character
would already have that's what it's
going to do now how is this cool you can
pretty much teach an illiterate to talk
like Shakespeare if you give a whole
bunch of like a whole like every single
play written by Shakespeare which is
also an example given in this brought in
this blog post if you give every single
single Shakespeare play this computer
would learn that this neural network
would learn that in the context of
Shakespeare plays after thou the most
likely word would be hast or whatever
you know so it's really cool it learns
the most likely word what this means is
it learns English or Spanish whatever
you're teaching it it doesn't really
know what's going on but it knows what's
the most likely thing to happen now I've
told you about this and I never have the
time to get into
of how to do this but I always still
have this code over here because it's
useful let's go super super fast it's
like five minutes left so what's going
on over here is this is just my imports
this is just remember I talked about
like how data is stored this is called
one-hot and coding where you have one
yes and then all of these years just to
show you the kind of data which neural
networks taken as inputs now so a lot of
the parts is these neural networks are
very complex in the way they're made
right but there are lots of tutorials to
tell you how to make these tutorial new
Olympics you don't make them from
scratch this is one way so you have like
a hidden dimension then you have what
the drop rate activation softmax all of
these are the characteristics of these
neural networks softmax is a kind of app
activation then you have drop rate which
is at what point do you stop were
fitting these are a lot of things which
are particular to particular to neural
networks and this is how we're creating
our model so I'm just running these
three functions so over here you have
certain characteristics of these neural
networks which again I do not possibly
have a time to explain it to you but I
would really recommend going and finding
out what exactly they do because
depending on how you want to keep these
parameters the way your neural everett
learns things are very different neural
networks also take a very long time to
actually train like hours days to Train
depending on how big it is right so all
this code over here will take you oh you
don't need to really pay too much
attention to it right now this is for
you all to try out when you're home or
wherever so this is what we're gonna be
doing to get our models this is how we
train it and now what we're going what I
told you before is I generate text right
so this is now our model that the code
the functions are done for training the
model this is how I'm gonna generate my
model it's basically up really really
fast right I start with a random seed
and then after that I basically say
based on the current word I make a
prediction of the Mishnah current
character not even sizzurp character
level learning model there's also a word
based learning model right this is
actually learned words on its own not
just it learnt it let's learn how to
make words not just what comes after
it's a pretty
clicks model so what's going happening
over here is based on the previous word
I'm gonna make it based on previous
character I'm gonna make a prediction on
what the next character is and it does
that and I'm gonna be using the lead
background corpus I had this game of
Thrones quote was just cool but I
totally legal you never saw that so I'm
gonna go back and use the the Lea
newspaper corpus which we're talking
about before and these are all my
characters and mapping and bambam
running a lot of code but basically the
point is what's happened over here is
I've used all that newspaper article
corpus to kind of teach this model of
what exactly did newspaper articles look
like in the Tatar and it's gonna do that
now it's gonna take some time to load
because it takes some but I want to very
very briefly show you some of like what
I've done is what you've seen is the
actual code of how to do this yourself
in this blog post which I've linked to
this over here over here
this is Shakespeare written by a neural
network this is not a human being this
is a neural network which has done this
I would have loved to show you
Shakespeare died myself but it takes a
lot of time to train these models so
this is an example from the blog post a
travelling to it is actually it has
learned how to write code it can do
latex it's it's pretty nuts you can do a
lot of very cool things about how useful
it is I'm not always 100% sure but it's
still it's still very interesting and it
could possibly have some business I'm a
researcher so I can just do things for
fun and not really care about how it's
useful in the real world but this is one
of the cool things you can also do so
that's pretty much what the tutorial is
I'm sorry for running through the last
bit of it I usually end up always doing
that but I want to include this in a
tutorial you can have the code and look
at it in more detail so this is
everything we've talked about it was
quite a lot I understand it was kind of
kind of fast and then lay you do the
stuff on your own but I do hope that you
would download all of these packages set
up your environment and be able to do
all these things understand why you're
doing all these things back whenever you
get more time
and thanks a lot for listening I am also
here tomorrow and on Tuesday I'm
speaking tomorrow where I will be tough
no I usually talk about this tutorial
kind of in my talk so this I'll be
talking about text analysis and the kind
of things you can do so if you wanted a
little bit more you can listen to me
I'm also easily contacta belong github
gmail whatever I'd love to get questions
or anything you'd like to ask me about
text analysis and thank you very much
[Applause]